[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life
where we sift through philosophy to find
practical advice you can use in your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my co-host
dr greg sadler and today we're talking
about
asymmetric knowledge problems and
some of the moral implications of those
and so
we've got a lot of examples lined up
this sounds rather abstract at first but
we're going to explain it in ways that
help connect to our everyday experiences
in life
and i expect that most people
you know once we explain what an
asymmetric knowledge problem is they'll
be like oh yeah yeah i face those
every single day right right
and it's kind of like there's always
you're like trying to rock for a word to
try to describe something and
you see it a lot of times like oh
there's a word that i just
heard about recently it's like the
feeling of of walking into
a spider's web and some
uh wordsmith like oh i can i'm gonna
apply a word to this because there's
there's no word that actually describes
this
well enough as like a singular term what
did they come up with
oh i unfortunately can't remember i
feel a little silly about bringing it up
words are failing you
yes um so uh this is uh
async asymmetric knowledge problems
otherwise known as
information asymmetry is just a
traditional
um a type of market failure so this
originally comes from economics
so you gotta explain you gotta explain
what a market failure is i think for
foreign
let me just finish the sentence of
market failure where one agent has
uh more or better information than the
other and so market failure
is uh within market theory
something that prevents uh an
equilibrium point
happening between supply and demand and
your supply and demand curves
and uh under an ideal market
and you know we have to call a deal
because usually they never exist
yeah yeah um but there's some
generalities of like
okay uh you're you're selling something
for
um x amount of price um and so
you say you're selling something for ten
dollars and only five people will buy
it but if you lower the price to eight
dollars all of a sudden 20 people will
buy it
and and that that and then if you go
down more than your uh you're red you're
going to the point where
it costs or you're selling it for less
than what you're actually producing it
and so then there's not an incentive to
make any more of it and so
the idea we're here is you're trying to
bring it to
the the lowest price that will uh get
everyone to
or the most people wanting to buy it you
know there's a classical
um asymmetric knowledge problem with
respect to buying and selling
with with grain that comes up in the
ancient world
and some of the different stoics weighed
in on it and they disagreed about
what was okay and what wasn't okay it
was if you
are in a city and you've got a
you've got a boat and it's laden full of
grain right so you're bringing wheat in
or barley or something like that
and the city has been suffering a famine
and you know that right behind you
coming in tomorrow are like a whole
bunch of other barges all full of grain
but you are pulling in that day
with the only grain that anybody knows
is there except for you do you
have to reveal that there's more grain
coming
and if you do obviously the price of
your grain is going to go down
or should you just sell it for as much
as you can
and it's interesting because one of the
stoic
uh skull arcs diogenes of babylon said
no no it's perfectly fine you could
you could do whatever you want with it
you have no obligation to tell anybody
that there's going to be more of this
product coming in and so they don't have
to pay you
you know premium prices and his
successor auntie potter said this is
something bad diogenes should not have
said this
it actually comes up in in one of
cicero's books where he's recounting it
that's the only reason why we
we know that this this exchange happened
and it seems like auntie potter thought
that diogenes was actually kind of a
kind of a shifty guy for suggesting
that it could be okay that the captain
or the owner
has no obligation to to reveal that
information
it seems a little bit at odds with some
of the very
uh pro-social uh underpinnings of
a lot of stoic thought it could be i
mean we don't know much more about
the thing i mean maybe diogenes would
have said well you know you can make a
lot of money
and then you can like spend it on
helping people
or something we don't we have no idea
you know we don't actually know that
much about diogenes other than
he was one of the representatives for
greek philosophy when they sent three
ambassadors
of philosophy to rome
and it was an unsuccessful mission
because the guy who was the
the representative of the academy which
at that time was skeptical
argued on one side of an issue the first
day then argued on the other side of the
issue the second day and so
some of the more conservative romans
were like look at these guys you know
you can't trust them on anything
and that's actually you know to come
back to the topic asymmetric knowledge
problems do involve
questions of trust right and and who we
who we can get information from and who
who we owe information to right
you said it was a failure didn't they
like they were
had a 500 talon um tax
levied on them and they are uh not a tax
but a um
fine levied on them did i not reduce
that uh
to like maybe 200 talons oh
the uh the ambassador uh thing yeah i
think that that's
that they were successful in that
respect but the romans
at least the conservative ones were like
no we don't want philosophy around here
you know
so it was unsuccessful as you're right
they they were successful in their
official mission
they are unsuccessful in their their
more
cultural mission you could call it
and thus starts uh is it like another
step in the long lines of the
romans throwing out philosophers that's
right
there were a few times when not only
individual philosophers got exiled
including quite a few of the stoics
for reasons we can talk about some other
time but there were there were a few
uh roman emperors who kicked
all of the philosophers out of rome uh
diocletian i think was one of them
and i mean imagine if you were like one
of the the uh
people practicing philosophy and
teaching people and you built up a
practice
in you know at that time it'd be like
sort of like being in new york city or
london or paris
and then suddenly they tell you okay all
of you get the hell out of here you
can't be
be around you know you're you're
destroying the culture
um if you don't get out of here we're
gonna you know we'll do something to you
i don't know what they what the
actual penalty was maybe it was death
maybe it was just you know
flogging or something like that you know
you were big fans of corporal punishment
that's true yeah
and and they did not like wait around
there wasn't like an appeals process
you know where maybe you do something
and then you go to trial like six months
later
and you know you go you go off to prison
and and uh then you go through all your
appeals no it was
like you know pretty pretty quickly uh
as a matter of fact if you don't mind
another
digression socrates right
big father of philosophy in so many
respects well he was executed
and and he was condemned to death and
the only reason he wasn't like
executed the next couple days was
because there was some religious
festival going on
and they didn't want to pollute the city
with executions
so he got to hang around and chat with
his friends for about a month or so
otherwise it would have been curtains
right away you know
right and and thank you for uh reducing
the asymmetry and knowledge of some of
our
listeners as we get back
to asymmetric knowledge problems yeah um
and so
now that we've talked a little bit about
some
market failures and what happens with
the asymmetric knowledge problem
often is that the the true
cost of something is either um
inflated or the um
the negatives of taking something are
um often uh that's um tamped down
in order to make it once again the the
value of the
object to be greater than what it is
and so yeah please well i was wondering
there's another kind of market failure
that we talk about quite a bit in
business ethics
negative externalities where you
displace
costs on to somebody and then the costs
aren't aren't actually taken into
account so like
pollution is a classic example um
sweatshops are another
example you know when you're when you're
buying what they call fast fashion
there's a good chance that there's some
misery built into
or baked into or woven into rather
the clothing that you're you're
purchasing and i mean we can say this
about so many other things as well you
know
our cheap meat comes uh because of
factory farming in large part right
and if you if you know about what what
happens in factory farming both to the
animals and to the
the people doing the work who are
usually pretty poorly paid and
working under you know bad conditions
and think about the environment
you you might say well i'm either
willing to pay more for
meat you know purchase it from an
ethical butcher
or i'm gonna you know be vegetarian
um so i mean do these externalities fit
in with uh
asymmetric knowledge problems um because
a lot of the times that as we'll
actually talk about a little bit later
the asymmetric knowledge problems um
hide or obfuscate
these negative externalities
that makes a lot of sense yeah and so
now you're not even aware that they're
happening it's like oh yeah it's it's
totally fine like you
you go to the store and you you buy a
you know a carton of eggs for a dollar
and not actually know what are all the
costs and you
um you you drive and you don't know
exactly what all the costs
you just went to the gas station you
didn't see anything and
it looks nice and shiny and clean at
your your local bp or something and
um but it you know a facade does not
give you all the information that you
need so
um
and and so if you but in away from the
negative externalities
if you're just talking about like uh you
for example this this person with the
grain and he knows that more grain is
coming over
you can say like oh yeah like i can um
there's no more grain coming so i'm
gonna jack up the price which then
reduces that person like oh well you
need grain to eat
but they're not that just taking away
other money that they might need for
other
uh you know basic needs maybe they can't
buy new clothes or shoes for their kids
or something you know and he doesn't
even need to like lie to them and say
there's no more grain coming he
he just has to like not say that there's
that that what he knows to be the case
these ships are coming in tomorrow
and the market's going to be flooded
with grain he just doesn't have to say
that
and he's already taking advantage of um
the fact that
most people believe that to be the case
right
or you know you also get this a little
bit if you're like the only one that can
provide something like even if it like
stuff might be coming you can you can
jack up the price um
even though you may be able to produce
more of it and reduce it yourself
but it that's just more work for you you
could even potentially make more money
but like hey
like what's a marginal increase in money
if i have to work 10 times as much
you know and there's a story about
another philosopher
who who did exactly that and and any it
was sort of a
in your face kind of thing right so
thales who
gets made fun of quite a lot because he
said everything was water and you know
how could anyone be so dumb as to think
that
um he he was a meteorologist
as well as a philosopher he's always
looking at the the sky
and he walked into a ditch and so some
some servant you know you know girl made
fun of him you know look at the stupid
philosopher you know
heads in the clouds and all that and as
it turned out
um he by virtue of of his um
meteorological observations he was able
to predict that it was going to be a
really good year for olives one year
and so he went around and he he got
basically like
options on all of the different olive
presses because
you know olives are no good if you can't
press the oil out of them
and so everybody who had this this great
crop then had to come to him
to press their their uh their oil and
and he
you know he could charge basically any
price that he wanted
because he bought you know as they say
buy low sell high right that's exactly
what this
this philosopher did and you know it's
interesting that you bring that up
because another kind of market failure
is monopoly right
or or anything that's like a monopoly
when you have a cartel
so i guess asymmetric knowledge problems
often lend themselves to monopolization
of
of uh information or resources or
whatever it is that we've got going on
right
correct and you know it was great for
thales but like if
he was the only one now uh all the
all the producers now like lost their
shirt that year
well i think they they prob he didn't
like charge them so much that they went
out of business but he could charge them
like say double what what they
normally would get they still had a
great year so they're still
making money but they're not making as
much money as they would if there was a
complete open market on olive presses
yeah it reminds me of um there was
i want to say it was either like cabbage
or potatoes where
someone basically bought it all the
yeah he totally cornered the market at
it and
and he was cutthroat in the point where
he um
made many farms go out of business oh
in that one year and so his name is mud
he made like
you know 100 million dollars in a day um
but within that farming community he is
like
you know the boogie man yeah yeah
um but yeah let's talk about some other
venues in which this this arises
so one of the big ones is is healthcare
um
especially in our country and so if
you're selling healthcare on
markets then that usually requires you
to have the ability to go and actually
uh test prices between different
providers
but when you're in an ambulance or
you're unconscious
you have zero to no chance of actually
doing this
yeah you know the the main thing is i
don't want to die
take me to the place that will make it
so i don't die
and these uh results
in one you know the the hospital can
basically charge whatever it wants
you know obviously there there are a
myriad of different problems with
the healthcare market this is just one
of them so i'm not going to try to throw
um all the problems at this one
instance of a problem this is a really
interesting one though because i've seen
a lot of
cases coming up where a person thinks
they're consenting to
something at one level of cost and it
turns out it costs way more or
you know that their insurance is going
to cover something and then it doesn't
cover it
and then somebody's got a gotta i mean
that's where a lot of these gofundmes
that we see on social media are coming
from right
right and and you're creating um
uh the procedures if you are like oh man
markets are
the way to actually like solve our
problems here um
that these are uh
totally disregarding the market people
get sick and hurt and are exchange
are charged excessive prices for
something that they can't refuse
otherwise the alternative is death um
and and so you we have a
incredibly large amount of medical
bankruptcies happening in this country
due to this
you know at least partly asymmetric
knowledge problems within this market
which
is failing constantly yeah it's
interesting because um
one of the one of the promises of like
having some sort of
like the affordable care act having some
sort of public health option
is that well this is going to deal with
these
these issues that are arising people not
being able to get you know
covered um and not being
essentially being the little person
against the big big
insurance companies right and in order
to use your
your insurance that you buy under the
affordable care act it's very byzantine
it's it's
it's there's so many hoops that you have
to jump through
you have to like make decisions at
certain times each year quite often
without you know
sufficient knowledge and you know unless
you actually like go through line by
line and look at what's covered and
what's not
from year to year they change it and so
something that you thought was going to
be covered
isn't it's not quite as bad as say like
a user agreement
you know almost nobody reads those right
but it is uh there there is definitely
an a asymmetry there
yeah especially because a lot of like if
you're looking at user agreements these
are written in legalese
a lot of the time and so unless you are
have a speciality
in that particular type of language and
the laws
that uh govern those particular type of
contracts
yeah it is very difficult for you to
have a good
understanding of what you're actually
agreeing to
that's interesting so you know we often
talk about like informed consent
as being important medical ethics in
particular but also like
in other areas this is a bit of a side
topic do you think it's possible to give
informed consent to the average user
agreement
um for most things like
itunes that we use or now it's it's
apple music
or some of these other things do you
think that the average person
can really give informed consent or not
i would say if your your document is
like a page long maybe
yeah but
30 pages or something and it's usually a
small typeface so it's
it is a massive block of text that is
you know i've uh helped in in
creating these documents it you know it
took us
like weeks to do it and
you know how how are you as users
supposed to understand this when you're
your your livelihood doesn't depend on
on
going into these things you just want to
get your music or you just want to get
your
yeah you know um you want to swipe right
for your date next
right yeah i i you know i think too
it would be very difficult to tell
what's changed i i like
that some of the um platforms that i
deal with will actually send an email
saying
here's the changes we made to the
agreement right
but usually they're kind of like high
level they don't tell you what the real
[Music]
uh nitty gritty particular you know
real granular level of changes are
yeah whenever i'm negotiating a contract
i actually use a
tool in computer science called diff
right so diff
diff is used to find the individual
lines of codes or individual characters
of codes
that have changed between two iterations
of code
that's interesting i use i use it like
oh here here's the revisions and we like
we talked about
we're going to talk about this revision
and this place and this place
and i go okay well let's see if this
this
is actually the thing i put the text in
one side and put the new text to the
other side
it goes here all the lines where there's
differences and i go and check them out
um you know usually they're fairly
straightforward but like it
it gives you that peace of mind that you
know that nothing is going to be put in
there
unbeknownst to you it also tells you if
there's some red flags that need to be
raised right because
i i guess we could talk about knowledge
asymmetry on
you know a base level and then we can
talk about it on a higher level
with things like that when when you know
you you don't
you remember that old rumsfeld uh thing
that differentiation between there's
you know things going on there's known
unknowns and an
unknown unknown so the the unknown
unknowns are the ones we really have to
watch out for right
we don't have any suspicion that
something has been changed or slipped in
there
you know unless we do the sort of
procedure that you're talking about
which
really would require having you know
something like a computer checking it
because
we're gonna catch it eyeballing it
ourselves right
um you know rum sold you know got
a lot of blow back from that but people
people talked as if he was stupid but
it's brilliant
oh yeah it is great but because you know
it was an unknown unknown they'd never
heard of this thing before
and it sounded like gibberish at the
very cursory look of it
but yeah it is incredibly useful
actually i've
i've used it a lot on in
in interviews i'm asking if you were me
like what would you ask or like if i uh
like because i don't know this job or
this employer as
well as you do uh what are the things
that i should have asked in this that i
haven't asked
what sort of what sort of answers do you
get out of curiosity when you do that do
they
just look at you like a blank stare or
do they have an answer at the ready or
does it like kind of
bother them the last time i use it the
guy said
that's a really good question well
that's a stall
well yes um but at least he wasn't
immediately dismissive of it
yeah um and so we were
um oh what was i doing it was
talking to you know i don't think i
could actually talk about that
um but it's fine uh i wasn't in
interviewing for a position but i was
uh getting information from another
company
okay in the relationship between my
company and theirs
um but uh yeah he actually came up with
something that was really good
um but once again can't say
well now you're imposing a knowledge
asymmetry upon us right
yeah and this brings us to if we want to
talk about it
on ndas and yeah yeah unfortunately
uh i i work in the tech industry um and
i've i've signed literally hundreds of
ndas
and these um are there obsessively to
protect the company and
and they can do that but they can also
be used to
stifle inner information being leaked
out and to
potentially stifle blowback on the
company for things that were kind of
like malfeasance or maybe even illegal
yeah it seems like one of the big
problems with ndas
and i think we can also associate with
this the requirement to go to
arbitration which has become more and
more part of people's
work contracts is that it doesn't allow
us so if we imagine an ideal marketplace
right
the the the general idea is that bad
actors are supposed to get a bad
reputation and
information about what they're doing
right what they're doing wrong is
supposed to get out there and then you
know if somebody has a lot of
you know bad reviews or black marks or
whatever we want to say
people will be less trusting of them and
maybe will impose a higher premium on
any sort of work that they do with them
but with ndas and arbitration it's
impossible many times to tell
who's good and who's bad right because
everybody's got this same slate
it's similar to what happened with uh
recommendations you know companies are
very leery about
saying that somebody wasn't a good
employee they'll just say well they
worked here at this and
that time i know people who get around
that by saying i'm going to talk about
the weather now imagine if the weather
showed up late
all the time there's ways to get around
that
but you know what this is it's providing
information that that people need so
if you have uh well so what what is the
the site is it front door that
it provides glassdoor right yeah so
i mean that's remedying that that
problem in many respects or
or you could think in like the academic
world
um no it's not perfect of course but
rate my professor
um some some schools use that quite a
bit and the schools don't use it the
students use it quite a bit yeah when i
taught at marquette
they would all tell me about you know my
rate my professor
things and that they use that um
teaching at milwaukee
in institute of art and design i asked
the students if they look at that and
they're like
we don't care about that it's all word
of mouth but still it's it's it's
information
you know getting out there so an nda or
get any spicy chili peppers
i used to a long time ago
not not any not any time in the last uh
couple jobs i think the last time i had
that was back when i taught at
fayetteville state university and that's
almost a decade ago so
um but it's it's um you know i i
myself i kind of i'm in favor of those
sorts
of things i know a lot of professors are
like oh these people are being mean and
the scores are not reflective of my
ability but it's kind of funny when i
when i like look at my
my peers um ratings and what the
students have to say about them the
qualitative stuff rather than just the
quantitative stuff
it's sometimes eye-opening you know
you're like oh man
i didn't know that about that person
especially when you see like
four or five students saying the same
thing about them you're like
you know they had me fooled
like i i had a
a company was trying to look for us to
be a contract at
my current company um and as they're
like
cold calling like hey we're trying to
drum up business and like who are these
people and i just
i i googled them and one of the first
things that came up was
on their review of employees and their
experience with this company
and oh man it was a bloodbath
um they just uh reamed them out at every
which way possible
and i'm like if you're if you treat your
employees like this
yeah you know you obsessively are like
part of your team how are you going to
treat me as a customer
so this is kind of something there's a
bit of a side note right
so we're digressing a bit but um
when there are these knowledge
asymmetries like a company wants to keep
anybody knowing whether they're a good
or bad place to work they want to have
everybody assuming that they're a good
place to work
is it really possible to control that
that information now in the internet age
when we we do have all these platforms
where people can
grouse about it i mean you can you could
like do a takedown order or something
but it's like playing whack-a-mole right
they could they could pop it up
somewhere else
um i mean there are there are going to
be exceptions to this but
does i mean does it seem to you that
it's more difficult to
conceal information about
you know being a bad agent in the
marketplace
now it's definitely more difficult to do
that there's a lot
more you know sunlight that is being
exposed out there and especially because
a lot of
companies are you know they might not
even be us based and so
like hey i had tried to do some sort of
takedown court order or something
it was like okay but there you're in
sweden and they're like i don't care
yeah yeah um that was a terrible accent
um and it wasn't identifiably swedish
that's for sure
but i was willing to go along with it
because you know
[Music]
um
but maybe back to some more examples of
asymmetrical college problems
um and you know i guess greg what is the
perception of a used car salesman
it's generally bad i mean i i actually
know a few people who have sold these
cars and um as far as i know they were
fairly decent people but i don't know
how they were on the lot
you know so
so um why is the perception of a used
car salesman bad
that's a good question um i mean there's
there's i guess they it must go back to
decades and decades ago when you would
sell cars that were
not worth the price that you were
selling them for
right and use rhetorical techniques or
things like that to get people to buy
them
or maybe you wouldn't honor commitments
that are that are made
yeah yeah i can see it like you know
there's that uh
i i remember like watching all the films
and like the carlos jazmin is like out
there
rolling back the odometer oh right
to my make the car look like you have
less miles and like
you know throwing some eggs in the
radiator so to like plug up holes but
then
that's eventually going to wear out and
so like it runs fine for
you know maybe a week and then it starts
all falling apart and you know the guy's
like well
you know uh you got a wheat to bring it
back but you didn't so
yeah sucks to be you i mean
you see like uh what is the
car carfax reports um
i was going to say carmax but i knew
that that was wrong that was the place i
was selling them right
um but yeah carfax yeah so you can't get
away with as much these days right
right and you know this is reducing that
asymmetric knowledge problem carfax
found a a market niche
where uh people wanted to know if the
car the used cars that they were making
on our actually
you know what they're purporting to be
and and give you some information about
that
like oh this one actually was win for a
swim or
this one was in a uh accent and the
frame is actually bent even though you
can't quite see it from the outside
and and so these yeah so that's so
that's a remedy right right
and so this is an example of a market
function fixing another of broken market
failure
yeah we can call it an equalizer right
right perhaps is is a
so let me let me ask you about uh
an example that i don't think we are
planning on
getting to but you kind of brought up in
a way
um like think about dating apps
and dating in general um
you never really know somebody until
you've been out with them
for quite a while unless unless you know
them like you know because you were
friends before
or you went to school together or you've
got people vouching for them
so is there i mean is there always going
to be like an asymmetric knowledge
problem involved in
people's romantic life and i mean is it
is it worse because of
um things like dating apps
uh i mean some of them are some of them
i guess you could actually know a lot
about the person because they ask you so
many different questions but
as people could always lie i suppose
right
and it and even if you're like oh yeah
that person sounds like
perfect and they're not actually lying
but you could like
get there and all of a sudden there's
something that just like totally pushes
you off it's so
it's such a hard thing to actually
quantify it's like yes that that
person actually will be good for you and
so we're all kind of going off of like
you know little heuristics here or there
and yeah um i guess part of the the
thing with these
dating apps is that you're now presented
with a a much
larger market of individuals
and now you have to figure out some way
to actually weed out this information
it's like okay i'm only
going to try to interact with this group
of people
and you and well yeah like how do you go
from a thousand
to maybe 10 to choose from to actually
choosing
you know three to go out with like you
you've only got so much time in the day
you also have to make sure like they
want to go out with you
um and
yeah you could say like well i'm i'm
only going to talk to you on
uh red heads that also die half their
hair blonde
and are between five foot eight and five
foot
nine you're really pricing yourself out
of the market there i think
at least here in milwaukee you know
maybe maybe in a bigger venue like
chicago or new york you might find one
but
uh i don't know about that um
but i guess that could be a long
distance relationship though right you
could
expand the pool worldwide but yeah as
you're saying like
there's a lot of people that like oh i
won't date anyone
under a certain height or under a
certain weight and so you see all the
time there's inflation of
of height and also deflation of weight
statistics you know for
men and women really respectively and
you know is i guess
the proof is in the pudding like can you
get in the door and
is it moral for you to lie in order to
get in the door to actually have
the interaction that is the true arbiter
of if someone is a good fit for you
you know that was as you're talking
about that i was thinking about
this and i wasn't going to ask the
question but now i am
um so no i've never used a dating gap in
my life right i'm happily married and
you know um that just that that's not
that's something
on my mind but i can well imagine having
known a lot of people
who are you know using them and seeing
uh quite a few sitcoms that there would
be
people where you show up and they don't
look anything like the picture
now should that be like an automatic red
flag of
well i'm not going to get straight
information out of this person because
they lied about you know something so
basic as
what they they look like and i'm not i'm
not talking about like somebody who
has somebody else's picture i'm talking
about somebody who like
maybe has you know their 12 year old uh
picture from back in the day and that's
that's what they
put there and now they're you know 12
years older and they look quite
different
um should that you know with these
asymmetric knowledge problems
and and also with the unknown unknowns
should we should we worry about red
flags
and say ah now i have to be much more
skeptical
now i have to like be alert to the fact
that
somebody might be trying to to snow me
like yeah with the used car thing right
you walk onto a used car lot
if you don't think to yourself there's a
possibility that this person is going to
try to bs
me you're probably putting yourself at a
disadvantage right now
with with people or you could also do
this with job things right you show up
to the to the job
and they're like well we closed that
position but we'd like to interview you
for another position now
if i hear something like that i'm like
yeah i don't know about that you know
yeah i think is a useful
bit of things to to talk about on
especially
you know if if you're doing a dating app
in order to actually look for a
relationship
um you know uh trust is a really strong
and an important uh foundational stone
and if you're basing it off of something
that is very
um you know already being deceptive at
the very beginning of the offset
then that that is probably a
particularly egregious red flag that you
should
pay close attention to
can we expand that brought more broadly
and say well if companies are going to
lie
to us then we probably should expect
them to lie the next time that they're
they're uh talking about something you
know if they're withholding
information um like you know for there
there was an
interesting thing that happened i think
it was in the summer
um somebody here in the downtown of
milwaukee
it was a construction crew they hit a
fiber optic cable
um i don't know if you remember this but
like the i remember in the tower
well the whole downtown was out of
internet for at least the day
and it got solved very quickly because
when the mayor's office and city hall
doesn't have internet you know
somebody's going to fix something
and that was part of the the blackout
area and
when you when things like that happen
right first your internet goes out and
you're like ah what's going on here
let's try to reset the modem
and then you call up the place and
they're like did you try resetting the
modem you know
and then you know pretty soon it comes
out that there's no this is a bigger
thing than than we thought
because you're looking at your phone and
you see like everybody in the area is
like what the hell what's going on here
and then you you like go to the the app
and the company and they're like well
yes there's they're indeed an outage
we're we're not quite sure what happened
we'll we'll get back to you when we do
you know when you're like when are you
gonna fix this well it could be a day it
could be a week
you know i don't know you know you know
that they know
right uh they have a pretty good idea of
what's going on most likely
but they trickle out the information bit
by bit by bit
now if they're if they're if you know
that they're doing that as a matter of
course
then you probably are going to be
skeptical
of most of the things that the the
company is saying right
i guess uh trust but verify is a useful
topic here
or a useful uh mode of interacting it's
like yeah
you know i'm gonna trust you
you know about as as much as it needs to
be
um but you know like make sure like
cross your eyes and
cross your t's and dot your eyes to make
sure that what they're actually saying
to you is is not
just bs um you know a healthy skepticism
especially as long as it's not like life
or death
things it's yeah verify
implies that you could go to some other
information source
and and get information right so i guess
in your example
like the other people around you that
say hey we're all down as well as a way
to like
at least verify when the guy you talk
him up it's like he's like
did you check your modems like yes i
checked my modem and also my neighbor's
mother and
and my neighbor's neighbor's mother you
know we were all down
i think it was social media that that we
were able to find out what was
what was what you know the the straight
dope as they used to call it right
that's somebody that somebody had hit a
uh cable and that
it had to be fixed and all that because
the company wasn't wasn't
putting that information out at all but
you know speaking of companies
what do companies sell but products and
there's a whole you know host of
different
uh companies and industries that have
produced products
in which uh they deceived
and obfuscated and did
put up lawsuits in order to prevent
certain information be made public
because it was usually a negative
externality of that product
you know one of the biggest ones is
cigarette companies
who uh knew for a long time that these
uh
their products that they sold the basis
of their company
yeah at least had a uh
correlation with uh cancer and
and as more studies became the you know
there was an absolute causation
but they they marketed them as healthy
they said like
oh you know this you know cigarette is
the one that your doctor chooses
and it leave the guy like be
in the the white lab coat and it's like
yes you know like you know palm balls
are the
you know the most smooth and you're like
for a healthy lung
smoke ball ball you know i i
don't know if that is actually what paul
mall said on uh
just right there was there was a
cigarette though that you're you're
right i remember seeing the ads
you know and there were some that were
like you know this will kill bacteria in
your throat
almost like gargling with listerine
right
um and
and so they like they they
uh they marketed and they
um tried to silence people that were
doing the science to
make this like a public health risk and
then they what was in the
80s did they get that giant on
it was towards the end of the 80s you're
talking about the big lawsuit
um yeah yeah it's been funding the truth
campaign for the last
30 years now yeah
the the anti-smoking campaigns
that that's right i remember uh when
that happened
i think i was um i think i was in high
school when when all of that was
was going on it was it was a very big
thing people a lot of people are very
surprised and i was surprised that
people were surprised because it said
on the packs by that time you know may
cause cancer
all these sorts of things but there were
in fact a lot of people who were like i
i couldn't believe these companies would
do this sort of thing
and you're like how do you you know how
do you not think that
oh my sweet summer child yeah
um you know another one here is on the
the oil companies have known
since like the 50s on that their
products
were having a detrimental effect on
the climate um their own scientists uh
came up with these reports and they uh
stifled them made sure that they didn't
see the live day
and as we have more and more information
at this point in time
it is absolutely apparent that uh
you know throwing a whole bunch of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
is has long-term detrimental effects on
uh the the temperature our ability to
grow crops the acidification of the
the ocean the uh all the food that we
rely upon
and it's and then they
they fought tooth and nail and there's
even still to this day
on the movement saying this is all i
don't know a hoax or just
normal uh variations in
the the carbon cycle and the the earth
and it's
it's absolutely you know right
you know one way that you can tell that
um
this you know that there is like this
withholding of information and spinning
information going on
is that just until recently
conservatives
in other countries didn't have any
problem believing in global climate
change
they become a bit more americanized that
way it's it's primarily in america
where there's this oh you know who knows
about the science and all that
that sort of you know casting doubt sort
of stuff uh in part because that
that's where most of the the companies
are based and that's where they spend
all the lobbying money you know you
can't actually spend as much money in
most other countries
on buying politicians as you can here in
the united states and so
yeah yeah the conservatives in other
countries are like yes this is the thing
we should be doing something
about it well you know what's really
interesting with this one
um and i i think we can find a way to
spin this into the knowledge asymmetry
the smart money conservative or liberal
or whatever
is on global climate change you look at
the insurance companies
uh who nobody really thinks of as being
you know politically liberal or anything
like that
they know that it's happening because
they're already like saying and we're
not sure we're going to
ensure these these you know areas on the
on the gulf coast anymore
or the rates are gonna go way up uh the
army
you know the rand corporation al all
these all these places that think about
like destabilization and global strategy
there they've been sounding the alarm
about climate change and the
dislocations that it's going to lead to
in terms of you know food and population
movement
for 10 years now so you know
in order to say it's not happening you
really got to go against a lot of
you know heavy hitters i think yeah what
the us military says the number one
um strategic problem in the world is
climate change
right yeah just like oh yeah that's
their entire job is to try to figure out
like
what are the dangers that could
potentially befall our country and
like this is number one it's like well
maybe we should listen yeah
um uh
so i and you know one of the reasons why
they're doing this is they know of 13
trillion dollars worth of
oil that is yet to be pumped out of the
ground and so they've got
13 trillion 13 trillion reasons
to try to block this
yeah and they might find more too you
never know oh yeah um
so uh you know another uh classic is
upton sinclair's jungle which was a
i o bit of yellow journalism bringing to
light
the uh malfeasance within the
meatpacking industry at the time
and how they were selling rotten
diseased and contaminated meat
directly to your home you know yeah you
know
that that old proverb if you don't want
to see how the sausage is
being made upton con sinclair showed you
how the sausage was being made and it
grossed a lot of people out yeah
and and it resulted in a massive amount
of
reform in the industry but like they the
meatpack industry was
not happy at all with them then bringing
yeah to white
this uh you know selling of you know
roadkill this is a really great example
though because and i think we can we can
apply this to other
food stuff today um
you know consumers really do need to
know
what's going into the stuff that they're
putting on their table and putting into
their stomachs
um and and there's there's so many cases
where
it's you know i suppose the information
is there but it's hard to access
or people don't know when they like
look at the ingredients they're not sure
how to
make sense out of whether it's good or
bad for them you know so this this um
brings up the issue of information
literacy that i think we should we
should talk about after you
go through a few more examples yeah well
um
maybe let's talk about uh quickly the
um i guess live markets
you know or wet markets that you find in
certain countries and how
this is a breeding ground for zoonotic
diseases and zoonotic diseases
are just those diseases that move
between
um humans and um animals and
usually it's it's birds that's you know
where we get flu and uh
sars and a number of other things as
well as i believe covid
um yeah although we sure we share a lot
of uh
uh stuff with with pigs too right that's
another sort of hotbed for that
and and putting together these markets
where you have lots of different
animals that are potentially disease
carriers and
stacking them on top of each other and
so they're you know feces
drops between them which is a vector for
uh
pathogens to move between these and that
is it's just
a breeding ground it's like you know i
don't know if this is exactly
this is like a black box asymmetry
because maybe the the people that are
selling don't even know how bad this is
and if they are told they might not
believe it
um because it's just what they've been
doing for such a long time
yeah you know and i brought up factory
farming
before in this i think we can say
something quite similar about
factory farming here in the united
states it's not like
the uh factory farming and and the
meatpacking industry you know
as it currently exists um it's not as if
we
recruit people who are particularly well
educated for these these sorts of things
it's it's primarily people who are
economically vulnerable
that wind up in these these jobs they're
often exploited
conditions you know safety things are
often not followed
and we're kind of like just almost
setting up a
a prime situation
for outbreaks of or transfers of
of diseases back and forth between
humans and animals you know
right and especially factory farming
there's a
very liberal use of antibiotics
which oh right right yeah create
help yeah antibiotic resistant uh
variations yeah yeah quite quite true so
so where does the knowledge asymmetry
come in i mean we could talk about it
knowledge asymmetry in terms of like the
people who are working there
not knowing how much at risk they are
i think there's for the owners knowing
that you know
they're trying to maximize profits
and they're not actually looking at this
negative externality and so um and and
we as
consumers of you know the pork that
comes out
on our uh plates um aren't
told uh explicitly that these are used
with a large amount of antibiotics
and the harms that that causes and so
you know if if there is any
um what is that uh
non-exploitive buying and capitalism
um this is extra bad
yeah and it this this is just a side
note but i mean it's become worse and
worse and worse
in recent decades um and it's not like
it was great when we were kids but
it's it's way worse now you know than it
was i mean
we we um pay an extra premium for
ethically
grown and harvested meat ourselves
because we we feel pretty strongly about
this
but i think most people don't know that
much about it you know i think maybe we
need a new
uh upton sinclair or something like that
for
our well we could but they outlawed uh
taking videos at
many factory farms true yeah
yeah that's true so um that that is
you know uh companies getting the state
to
enforce uh information's asymmetry
yeah so so there's at any given time
there's like a lot of different forces
kind of jockeying right there's
companies want to keep control over
information as much as possible
um oftentimes they'll use the state
which sometimes has a real interest in
like keeping things under wraps as well
and then we've got the internet which
you know it can be very helpful in that
you can share information but then
quite a bit of the information can also
be disinformation
right companies can just as easily like
send a a bunch of astro turfed uh
twitter
bots to to tweet about whatever whatever
line they have or pick
you pick any other sort of scenario you
want so either you know it's not as if
we have an
easy solution to this right
right um maybe talk about um like a
little bit of information
literacy and overload and maybe that
will bring us to something
yeah so let's talk about information
overload
this is something i notice with my my
students who often
are not particularly information
literate meaning they don't know
where to go to get information or how to
do research or stuff like that
when they do start looking for things
it's almost like the proverbial fire
hose coming at them
and they don't know how to sift the
relevant
sources or the relevant bits of
information apart from the stuff that's
not
particularly helpful you know so you
know a good example of um
of this sort of thing is going you know
just googling
and taking like the top 10 things that
come up those those probably
are not the best information sources in
most cases um
they may lead you to better sources like
wikipedia has gotten quite a bit better
over the years
there's still some areas where it's kind
of kind of you know
but the sources section at the bottom
like hey look i can find some primary
sources
yeah sometimes you know i look at things
where i
have a competency in that and i'm like
there's better sources that they could
have put there but this is this is what
the editors have done
and it's better than nothing right um so
information literacy is knowing there's
a whole bunch of
uh components to it as a matter of fact
the the library association
um you know they're they're the ones
who've done a lot of work on this this
sort of thing i did a fellowship with
them years and years ago the acrl
about information literacy and how to
incorporate it in our classes because
our students
they they often don't have any idea
where to go to get get better
information like what are the good
sources how do you
how do you determine what counts as as a
good source how do you dig
deeper and deeper and deeper and so
you know i know we're getting close to
running out of time i'll just say this
that that it's really
important that people don't just
pick the first source out there but
start you know exploring around to try
to find
better and better information it's like
a iterative process right
and the more you know the more you know
that you don't
well that and that can be a bit dismayed
so
maybe maybe where we want to end before
we yeah we get to the final thoughts is
is like
on a note of optimism right we've talked
so much about like what we don't know
but we we are in a better position than
say
20 years ago or 40 years ago like when
we had card catalogs that we'd have to
go to or like
look at the reader's guide to figure out
what what newspaper or magazine we'd go
to to get the information now
so much is available at our fingertips
yeah and it's it's a
fire hose and how do you properly
kind of like curate that fire hose to
actually get you
the the best and that's an
unsolved problem at the moment and i
think the the best thing we have for
that is maybe
you know people in the library sciences
to that that's their entire
job is to try to suss out a lot of the
best information so
so maybe uh what we want to say is
people need to to go to the librarians a
lot more right yeah
they're not just to find you books
they're they're there for all sorts of
other
things go go give some love to your
librarians
so we got some uh a final thought in the
words of upton sinclair
it is difficult to get a man to
understand something
when the salary depends on him not
understanding it
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign